welcome to this video playing veena
Marino V now Marie now ok let's see a
plate d4c form and the big choice now
the bank career and very popular in the
US ok very go to to an english opening
instead let's see what is doing okay
just just stop playing d5 in this game
this can easily transpose to the maroc
see point until we we went down that's
nice one of my favorite openings for
white i played the white side of them
roxy really countless times you get it
so often if you play mc4 neither three
openings i did some usually quite
comfortable for white you get a nice
central control Black has some we
limited account a plane are interesting
yeah I don't want to edit that I never
really saw this this line so early 97
it's interesting though if I play Bishop
e3 which would be yeah normal not
trading too many pieces then then this
may be Bishop takes you three as weird
as it looks it's not not terrible but ok
I want to play with f4 here if I yeah I
agree to the trade but I will play with
f4 so I didn't play a 4 immediately as
he can take and play Queen B 6 to trade
Queen so no I want to avoid
simplifications here Bishop default
Queen D for Queen B 6 is just bad
because of Queen d2 and 95 coming yep
now Queen B 6 is useless ok he's playing
a five so he wants to maybe I should
have played b3m yeah this is really not
good because he runs into 95 m of course
I will never trade and now while he
allows that
95 95 94 9692 look T 1 Alice wins
material so 95 he has to return to the
ad and then maybe it's not really so
great to play 95 at the moment better to
prepare it 95 28 I don't really have
such a great continuation after that
when 24 is not bad but let's say he
plays boo should be six it's not so
clear what my next move is I can I can I
can improve the position a bit so okay I
is playing very quickly like it's the
easiest position in the world and it
really isn't it really is not ok let's
see 95 now and maybe something with f5
Bishop d7 invites f5 in a way because
the bishop is some blocking the d7
square for the night mmm 5 and 95
there's also a 5
okay I'll play that now and see from
here 24 now on is them is something
better like a five for example f5 to to
get straight to h6 f5 night XD form
Quinn to age 6 it does not look like it
does winning immediately
f 594 Queen f4 maybe the reason why I'm
thinking about this for so long is
because if I get in let's say f6 f5 f6
then the dark squares would open up to
my attack area very dangerous but I
don't it seems that I don't I cannot get
it to work so I blame him i'd like to
get to to h2 to h6 but it's simply not
possible maybe if you place 96 year
again quickly no it doesn't um and so
right here it maybe take you can take
yeah well no f5 is pretty pointless
hmm
yeah I'm not sure ever should allow him
to trade on d5 well ed five is good for
white but yeah sure many possibilities
ok I'll I'd set it up so that's taking
that the rook is right for the structure
after Bishop takes d5 my bishop only two
is not doing a great job here
I don't see a very clear way forward at
the moment this is why I'm a bit taken
aback here this most like night Queen B
6 they really didn't really weren't so
good and I thought I should have more
when this is not bad but now I thought
that I should have more but i don't i
don't really have more than this very
comfortable but but not totally
dominating position maybe I should
really put the bishop to deform at least
controlled c8 and okay so we get an
entirely different thing okay one can
probably hear on 2d to know better am
just keep you three protector I don't
really get the move okay yeah where I
cannot cannot be bad now ok so here I
can even play a five not sure if I if I
benefit from that but I could do it 97
nerves the problem
yeah it's probably not a great idea I
should probably just a double on the
double triple or whatever on the EVO the
question is how exactly probably Bishop
to see to yeah okay maybe it's it's an
interesting question what to do about
this spawn exactly yeah now f5s may be
interesting ses neglected as neglected
f7f 597 takes g 6 ft 6 rook is 6 is not
working it's not far off though after
Bishop t2 i think I'm threatening at
five this is certainly dangerous
yeah but I have G form let's let's
consider g4 here g form
yeah yeah it should be all right i mean
he can play e5 or e6 but g4 must be the
right move ok didn't consider this even
this was the only only try a defense e
six or five this is now just yeah this
will get quite bloody I think too much
too much on the king queen to g5 Queen
to h6 and you cannot move the upon now
yeah there is no movie but maybe some
sort of way to hang on but there is
nothing I'll just break through maybe
who can what is relatively best here
maybe 97 now I don't know it's probably
am probably a pretty a pretty lost
anyway I mean all pieces I involved in
their tech yeah but what I am thinking
Queen g5 and Queen takes at five yeah
it's probably the easiest with late on
age seven yeah that's really made next
move cannot prevent that 94 but I
shouldn't pre-move 94 as possible it
would be very embarrassing pre moving
queen age 7 and then he plays 94 reason
okay so it was they played some strange
moves but it didn't really lead to a
total disaster maybe I just played it
badly as as possible the computer is as
usual much more forceful it wants to
play a five year okay okay this this is
indeed much more aggressive it wants to
play a five year with the idea that i
that i mentioned 94
and f6 and the big point is after King
g7 there is 95 queen d 89 txt 7 and this
is a total it totally totally destroying
em very nice okay I went I went for this
lame move Bishop d7 yeah and um yeah
this is nice and everything but not
devastating as as it was possible a here
94 very nice defense by but the engine
takes c6 aunt is getting the the night
back it is it is nothing greater
probably for why taya and I'm a bit a
bit more active and have this f5 idea
but it's not sure not sure that this is
anything right maybe it's slightly
better for mind at best okay and this
was played and I think here I should be
should be fine again yeah f5 immediately
assume is also good there wasn't I
wasn't totally sure you know yeah always
must be cautious with giving away those
squares especially e5 this can be a
terribly good piece on e5 the the
problem though is that just by concrete
means I'm good here with rook lifts so
f5 was good and here here at five was
also very strong can I can i play rook
f7 here no Queen h6 is a window yeah
it's not too surprising actually there
is a rookie six for example this idea or
here rookie 32 h three okay so this was
again a lame move and here he must play
he sings really
he didn't know g4 and here it gets very
tricky he six is the only try for
defense absolutely only try and yak 22
it's the the best move probably getting
out of the e-file if it takes now take
here and i have f5 next it will be a
very dangerous attack but you can at
least try but this this is now
devastating i wonder if the computer
will find a mate of you let it run for a
couple of minutes but it's on plastics
which is pretty pretty clear check yeah
only shouldn't pre-move queen h7 here
because the citizens and this is not not
yet no dryer this is a draw that's funny
this is with no whites winning that's
cool the computer finds a win even here
with this blunder okay let's check this
just just I mean it's completely
irrelevant but it's funny this is a win
for white that that's cool I know ki
it's it's it's a strong attack out
obviously Quincy aid is the best okay
group which is I want check King here if
you go back check check you get you get
checkmated here ok so here look 6 King
here and no this one amazing
what is the mating thread Bishop d1
check is the mating threat computer
defense with this check now this one if
you go there there's Bishop d1 mating
nice so must go here yeah now Bishop f5
wins the Queen back oh wow ok and now
this is five points against tier 11 pawn
and well this is a very precarious
situation ok it's a completely idiotic
line retakes h7 of course between d4 has
just made next move but just for the fun
of it this is even this is winning nice
ok well thanks for watching